wrights have been milling flower in
essex for 150 years but they've rarely
seen anything like the impact of the
invasion of ukraine which has brought
russian tanks to the wheat fields of one
of the world's largest producers in the
last two weeks we've seen wheat prices
increase by more than 30 percent
so
now getting into the regions of 340
pounds a ton which is unheard of we've
never seen wheat prices at that level we
will need very soon to get flower prices
uh increased through into the market
otherwise at these sort of levels mills
will go out of business
in the last month wheat prices have
soared reaching almost 13 a bushel
that's enough for 90 white loaves
wheat is a crucial commodity the source
of 20 of the world's protein this is a
global problem that will be felt at
kitchen tables any serious disruption of
production and experts from the you know
from this region from ukraine from
russia
will erode food security for millions of
people around the world you will feel
the impact in the uk you will feel the
impact in many places in europe and
especially in the most vulnerable and
countries like the middle east africa
some countries of asia
wheat is not the only commodity under
strain the london metals exchange has
suspended trading in nickel a key
element in stainless steel and electric
car batteries after the price quadrupled
commodities are the golden thread that
run through the global economy or in
this case copper this doncaster firm
makes a million metres of cable a week
and prices are rising even the wooden
drums are made of russian timber there's
a lot of uncertainty with copper
we don't actually know the price of
copper when we're ordering it so we
order in the morning and make a
commitment and if the price is volatile
we end up paying a lot more than what we
thought we're gonna pay
um in a week 70 tons
10 days ago that cost us about half a
million pounds to buy 70 tons and now
it's over 550 000 pounds
rising prices on the factory floor at
tomorrow's household inflation with
inflation already at a 30-year high the
bank of england was telling us that this
was going to be the sharpest fall in
living standards on record what's
happened is the situation in the ukraine
has made that more intense we'll see a
big squeeze on incomes
across
across the board everyone will feel that
through higher prices and it'll erode
everyone's wages
the bank of england had baked in
inflation at seven percent next month
before the invasion the economic war is
triggered means that may just be the
start paul kelso sky news